hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
torten willst die kulisse hier kennt ihr
wahrscheinlich schon aus meinem semester
video
ich bin nämlich seit einer woche wieder
in der türkei das heißt wenn ihr das
video steht war ich letzte woche in der
türkei aber jetzt bin ich halt jetzt
gerade in der türkei also bald wissen
lustig aber ich lag zerstören will ich
wieder daheim bin ja so ist es halt
wir müssen jetzt einfach ein paar tage
hier weil wir unser bisschen entspannen
wollte denn die letzte zeit war ziemlich
anstrengend vor allem hatte ich ja auch
die messe in hamburg die sehr schön war
aber sehr anstrengend war und dafür das
ganze nicht so unterschätzen mit den
youtube-videos wir drehen der drei
videos pro woche bzw drehen mehr pro
woche aber drei werden ausgestrahlt und
dann immer das ganze drumherum mit dem
blog berichten kommentare beantworten e
mails beantworten das ist natürlich
ziemlich anstrengend und deswegen haben
wir jetzt eben diese auszeit gebraucht
und ja sind wir hier in unserer anlage
der grund meines heutigen video
ich wollte einfach nur sagen und zwar
ich lass einfach raus ich bin schwanger
ich habe ich mir was richtig cooles
überlegt und zwar habe ich das mal
geträumt da war ich noch ned schwanger
aber wir haben zu planen schwanger zu
werden und dann habe ich geträumt dass
ich mal so eine torte backen ohne
babybauch torte und euch dann praktisch
am ende des videos tage und so eine
torte könnt ihr übrigens machen wenn ihr
eine baby shower party macht oder wenn
eure freundin schwanger ist oder wenn
ihr eure schwangerschaft verkünden
wollten hallo ich bin auch schwanger
aber das hat geklappt denn ich bekomme
schon seit wochen keine ahnung ich
glaube schon seit februar bekomme ich
ständig kommentare ob ich schwanger bin
und deswegen habe ich gar kein sally
lasse sei nicht einfach so weil
mittlerweile hat echt schon überhand
genommen und ich musste das jetzt echt
mal loswerden
und natürlich hätte ich euch schon viel
früher dran teilhaben lassen und hätte
am liebsten direkt erzählt also ich
wusste es seit der ambiente also am
letzten tag auf der ambiente wusste ich
praktisch dass ich schwanger bin
und unter dem video das war ganz komisch
wurde ich auch das erste mal gefragt
also das war irgendwie keine ahnung
sieht man das dann im gesicht jemanden
an
oder vielleicht strahlt man da anders
keine ahnung ich war da mega glücklich
auf jeden fall wurde ich seitdem schon
gefragt und ja also es ist so wir haben
es geplant und erwarten jetzt nachwuchs
dieses jahr im oktober man aber trotzdem
überrascht weil klar plant man sowas und
legt sich halt ins zeug
sozusagen
aber trotzdem ich war überrascht wenn es
dann halt glaubt und dann ist halt so
und ja die samira freut sich auch schon
total
sie durfte es auch selber im
kindergarten verkündete was ja auch ganz
stolz drauf und freut sich sehr auf ihr
geschwisterchen oder gebrechen wir
sommer nämlich es selber nicht was es
wird
hauptsache gesund und ja es war geplant
trotzdem so überrascht wie soll ich sie
sind euch jetzt nicht vorher schon
gesagt habe als sicher so ich meine wer
schon mal schwanger war weiß es auch mal
wartet halt gerne die ersten drei monate
ab weil es inhalt so die riskanten
monate und da kann noch viel schief
gehen das heißt man kann also dass die
das risiko für eine fehlgeburt höher und
wenn mal müsst euch überlegen wie man
jetzt verkündet hallo ich bin schwanger
in der sechsten woche und dann passiert
irgendwas und alle fragen dich dann
ständig wie läuft's wie läuft und du
musst dann irgendwie sagen irgendwie als
kind verloren oder so das ist ein bissl
blöd also so war es zum beispiel bei
einer freundin von mir da wusste dann
der enge bekannten und freundeskreis und
dann wird eben auch immer darauf
angesprochen deswegen finde ich es auch
ganz normal wenn frauen das zum beispiel
bis zum dritten monat sogar ganz für
sich behalten oder so nur mit ihrem
partner teil
aber ich habe natürlich gleich mit
eltern und sogar einheimische also ja
auch und ich finde ja man sieht schon
als ich habe zugenommen und es ist kein
geheimnis
aber ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen also so
jemandem unter alle beatles zu schreiben
salitos zogen um das ist echt schwanger
aus oder sogar zu schreiben du bist
schwanger jetzt gibt es doch zu finden
war grenzwertig als ich durfte mir
wahrscheinlich nicht erlaube einfach so
mal zu nehmen weil dann wird man gleich
kommentare kriegen
dabei finde ich es noch gar nicht so
schlimm naja wie auch immer
ja also das ist natürlich jetzt ist es
ziemlich schöne nachricht also für uns
zumindest für unsere freunde von meiner
familie auch natürlich muss man so ein
bisschen was umplanen weil alles was
jetzt bisher geplant hatten echt schön
und gut aber jetzt müssen wir natürlich
oben die schwangerschaft herum planen ja
ganz normal
im moment geht es mir auch echt super
gut und ich hatte zwar so wissel
übelkeit und alles aber so schlimm ging
es mir eigentlich nicht wobei ich die
ersten monate ich sehr müde war also ich
weiß nichts dagegen mir das noch nie ich
war noch ich bin eigentlich immer
ziemlich fit unsere unseren
frühaufsteher aber die ersten monate ich
hätte echt ich glaube ich 20 stunden
durchschlafen können das war wichtig
kräftezehrend musikshow sage aber der
murot kennt nicht so eigentlich auch
nicht geld das ich dann schlaff bis
morgens um neun es war schon heftig aber
es gehe ist es wieder gut
und genau dann ist ziemlich viel drum
herum planen also es gab er ein ganz
großes projekt wo ich mich darauf
gefreut habe und dass da blutet mit am
meisten des herzens warten wer den
globus shop geplant bzw meinen eigenen
shop im globus mit meiner buck schule
kochschule und eben noch meinem online
shop praktisch als stationären laden und
das ist jetzt ein projekt was wir leider
jetzt erstmal auf die warteliste setzen
müssen weil es einfach zeitlich nicht
geht also ursprünglich war geplant dass
es im märz mit zwischen märz und mai
eröffnet
das hat leider von von der globus seite
aus jetzt sage ich mal nicht gepasst
weil eben da die plänen und ich da waren
und es wird jetzt alles umgebaut
internet oder jetzt wird gerade umgebaut
und zeitlich constantin dass die läden
dann im mai eröffnen also das geht dann
eher so in den herbst im
september/oktober und da weshalb für uns
zu spät weil ich kann halt net vier
wochen bevor ich ein kind krieg also
hochschwanger praktisch im neunten monat
dann noch einen shop eröffnen also das
geht nicht es war einfach viel zu viel
stress für mich für den murat dann auch
und ich denke einfach da gibt es einfach
jetzt erstmal wichtigere dinge auf die
wir uns konzentrieren müssen und das
muss halt erstmal warten also es tut mir
auch echt am meisten leid denn
wir hatten praktisch alles schon also
theoretisch hatten wir alles schon
fertig praktisch musste ist nur
umgesetzt werden
ich hatte schon mein ladenbauer der
hatte schon sein konzept ich hatte sogar
schon meine küche drin geplant bekommen
ich habe meine auf der ambiente
jahrtausende produkte ausgesucht mit
denen ich hätte den laden ausstatten
können
ich hatte schon eine mitarbeiterin die
praktisch den laden sogar geleitet hätte
und so weiter und so fort
also es war echt schon alles fast
gestanden aber jetzt haben uns hat mit
murat hingesetzt haben da kommt es jetzt
so unvernünftig wenn wir das jetzt
machen
deswegen musste slider ist erst einmal
abgesagt werden
ja und bei uns ist ja auch so der murat
arbeitet er auch und im prinzip machen
wird das mit youtube ja auch weil es uns
einfach spaß macht theoretisch können
dich morgen aufhören damit und könnte
dann in die schule gehen und als
lehrerin arbeiten aber es macht halt
echt gerade viel spaß ich kann mich noch
total entfalten ich kann total neue wege
einschlagen und dass das ist einfach so
was was uns gerade ein bisschen
herausfordert und so viel spaß es mir
auch macht mir ist die karriere hals
zwar wichtig aber natürlich geht die
familie beimer vor
also ich hätte auch schon zigmal meine
wohnung verlassen könne und mein
familien und freundeskreis hinterlassen
können und wegziehen können um zum
beispiel eine fernsehsendung zu machen
und das passt aber zu uns also ich bin
da halt mehr so ein familienmensch
ich bleibe gerne in waghäusel vielleicht
eine umgebung aber hat weiter weg als
zehn kilometer und da bin ich so ein
bisschen jura die wissen genau ich
wollte mal sage ja auf jeden fall ja das
passt hat annett und ich finde familie
ist sowieso das wichtigste auf der welt
und deswegen habe ich mich da eben oder
haben wir uns dazu entschlossen jetzt
erstmal den globus shop nicht zu machen
und es einfach mal hinten dran zu
stellen
ein backbuch kommt noch genau das thema
jetzt gerade dran damals auch den fokus
darauf gelegt weil so langsam müssen
echt mal ein bisschen fertig werde damit
dass jetzt dieses jahr endlich rauskommt
da freue ich mich auch schon riesig
darauf und ich habe ja auch noch die
cache welt messen wo ich dann dabei bin
hamburg damals schon hinter uns war
wirklich schön jetzt demnächst kommt
friedrichshafen danach kommt wien und
wien ist der erste
september also friedrichshafen ist von 8
bis 10 mai wien ist vom irgendwas mitte
september ich glaube 13
september herum und da jetzt natürlich
doppelt schwierig weil ich nach
hochschwanger bin als ihr dürft mich
halter netzwerk um arme weil dann
plötzlich wahrscheinlich irgendwann ich
weiß sogar die ina kaiser meine freundin
kommt auch schwangere sicher auch
lustige dorf sagt er viele es gibt ja
viele inas auf jeden fall freue ich mich
da auch schon drauf und ja bei der messe
in hannover das im oktober
da kann ich ehrlich gesagt nicht zu
sagen weil wir im oktober unseren
nachwuchs erwarten
220 luxuriöses modische das ist dann
ernst dass du jetzt mutterschiffs jetzt
hast du dich alle frauen mit mir auf
jeden fall ist es halt dann
wahrscheinlich mir zu anstrengend dass
ich dann nach hannover und ich weiß auch
nicht wenn wenn unser nachwuchs früher
kommt man extra cissé erledigt also
wahlweise sehr nett dass ich ja immer
nur ein geplanter termin und man kann
das sei nie voraussagen wie gesagt
hannover kann ich nicht garantieren
wien auf jeden fall wenn es
gesundheitlich alles gut geht und so
weiter also wenn es so läuft wie bis
jetzt
dann ist wien auf jeden fall sind auf
jeden fall mit dabei ich freue mich
schon extrem auf wen ich war noch nie in
wien
und da habe ich sogar geplante paar tage
früher anzureisen damit ich mir
wesentlich stadt anguckt kann ein echtes
sacher torte essen kann
wer redet von dir also ich gehe auf
jeden fall wenn ich nach wien gehen dann
gehe ich ein paar tage vorher hin und
gucke mir die stadt an es eine
sachertorte das will ich nämlich schon
lang machen damit ich endlich mal eine
sachertorte rezept machen kann also
morath ob der freistaat mir scheißegal
die leute kommen sie ja wahrscheinlich
da kriegt schon deine david hasselhoff
maske ja das war es eigentlich schon im
prinzip also ich habe jetzt die katze
aus dem sack gelassen oder so wie man
das jetzt auf gut deutsch sagt ich hätte
gerne ein bisschen schöner und lust
darüber gebracht aber naja hamas halt
mal so ich okay oder
ich habe jetzt in der türkei bisserl
umstandsmode gekauft leider nur
dreiviertel hose denn in meiner lage
finde ich leider nichts wäre jetzt ein
tipp für mich hat kann wir gerne
schreibe weil lange hose finde ich in
der schwangerschaft gar nicht das ist
immer ein ziemlich großes problem bei
mir gerade so als wäre schon fünf mal
schwanger gewesen ich war ging es zum
zeitung na ja auf jeden fall vielleicht
habt ihr noch fragen
dann könnt ihr gerne in die kommentare
schreiben vielleicht hat jemand mit mir
schwanger und hat da noch fragen
vielleicht ich immer zum ersten mal
schwanger oder zum zweiten mal
oder hat noch tipps für mich könnte mir
nämlich auch gerne schreiben und wenn
ihr gerne zum beispiel so updates dann
ab und zu mal sehen wollt also was was
nicht mit einem rezept zu tun hat so was
die schwangerschaft zum beispiel
betrifft und so weiter könnte mir und
schreibe und ansonsten ja jetzt ganz
neues thema eröffnet generator zur
schwangerschaft kinderwunsch kind geholt
neugeburt nett aber halt alles was
danach kommt nein drei hosen kreißsaal
twitter sowie williams murat der rasende
reporter
nein das bleibt ganz mit 42 24
das bleibt privat ja auf jeden fall
kommen dann danach bestimmt säugling
nicht säuglingsnahrung zur babynahrung
und so weiter kann man dann alles dieses
jahr ansprechen wo genau und türkei zwei
dieses jahr geplant ich wollte nämlich
dem rad einpacken und noch zwei
kameraleute und dann einfach mal ne
türkei tor mache weil mir morath allein
ist ziemlich anstrengend denn wir haben
nur die eine kamera und brauchen
praktisch dann eine zweite kamera
weil es einfach aufwendigere videos sind
wenn man so eine türkei vor machen will
ich's halt wie sonne er wie so eine doku
mache oder halt immer zum beispiel mal
nach anteil der fahren und da so
sehenswürdigkeiten aber nicht so turi
mäßig sondern so richtig so alles was
die einheimische dort so erlebe und und
die anlage die ferienwohnung zum
beispiel für die ihr euch alle
interessiert die werde ich euch dann
zeige ich werde euch restaurants zeigen
wo er eben essen gehen könnt und ja ein
paar tipps und tricks auf jeden fall war
geplant seine komplette türkei tue aber
ich glaube dass ich mit diesem sommer
ein fachwissen zu anstrengend
im sommer in der türkei sehr heiß ist
und ich denke mir war das so auf das
gebiet am thalia begrenzen oder murat zu
machen ist und wenn alles gut geht kann
ein echtes hat die ganze türkei mache so
machen wir das einfach ich kenne es
jetzt noch meinen letzten sonnenstunden
und doch genau 40 ungefähr so sind noch
vier stunden ungefähr und morgen früh
reißen wir leider schon wieder ab oder
haben wir das hier nicht mehr rasch
wieder deinen kam ob la da draußen was
ein wischmopp er hat heute wieder
schwäbische gemacht aber ich war
ziemlich staubig deswegen alles gut bis
sie uns auch so falls sie übrigens
wissen wollte wie weit ich jetzt schon
wie kann schon mal stehen bleiben
ich bin jetzt im vierten monat